[Music]
i'm a clown but i'm not going to hunt
you in your dreams
i am not that
[Music]
i'm a clown but i'm not scary i'm a
clown but i'm not going to hide in the
woods and try to drag you in there with
me
but i'm not a bad guy but i don't look
like this
that's not a real clown and i should
know because i'm a real clown but i'm
not here to chase you with a machete
i won't be waiting in your closet when
you get home i'm not
a bully i'm not a psychopath i'll never
hurt you
what you've seen in the news is not true
all week there's been rumors that clowns
are going to come shoot up the school
there's a lot of bad publicity about
clowns
you the clown that was scaring the kids
back there creepy clowns going after
people with police
increasing patrols in a north carolina
neighborhood after two children
reportedly saw a clown
criminals that's when they thought now
they're gonna come and hunt us could we
send a message
to these people who are doing this take
the masks off
with your own face you guys are just a
damn disgrace to the whole nation
i'm a clown but i'm not your stereotype
this is my job this is an art form and i
would never hurt anybody and i'm italian
and i love to play i'm silly
and clowns love to laugh
[Music]
[Music]
you